malgré tout est bien le dialogue
continue sergueï lavrov rencontrera bien
jeudi l'américain anthony blinken
bonjour sonia dridi vous êtes à
washington on reste malgré tout là bas
très alarmiste
oui joe biden s'est dit prêt hier à
rencontrer le président en russie une
invasion n'a pas eu lieu d'ici là à
n'importe quel moment qu importe le
format la maison blanche assure être
toujours prêtes pour la diplomatie n'est
en réalité washington reste très alami
alarmiste ce matin sur la chaîne nbc le
conseiller à la sécurité nationale du
président james sullivan a déclaré nous
n'abandonnons pas la diplomatie tant que
les chars ne roulent pas mais vu le
mouvement des troupes russes la
possibilité d'une solution diplomatique
diminue chaque heure il a aussi précisé
que selon leurs informations et bien là
les russes planifié une attaque
extrêmement violente
on sait aussi que selon le washington
post et bien les etats-unis ont averti
l'onu de qu'il disposait d'informations
crédibles selon lesquelles moscou et
bien disposerez d'une liste noire
d'ukrainiens à éliminer ou envoyé dans
un camp en cas d'invasion les activistes
journalistes membres de la communauté
lgbt seraient particulièrement visées
donc la maison blanche reste très
alarmiste alors d'un côté divulguer ou
faire fuiter les plans de moscou c'est
un moyen de tenter de les déjouer mais
les officiels de l'administration maiden
sont aussi à la remise parce que ils
disent disposer d'informations
inquiétantes et ils sont de moins en
moins optimistes pour la possibilité
d'une solution diplomatique
merci souviendrai dit depuis washington
pour france 24